il y a plusieurs années je crée ma
première entreprise à l'époque je
travaille avec les amis dans un grand
groupe tout se passe bien on s'ennuie un
petit peu et on a une idée qui nous
trotte dans la tête on se dit mais
pourquoi n'est pas la faire valider par
une étude de marché on se tourne vers
vos cousins de l'oignon et on leur
propose ce projet au niveau des
dernières années pour qu'ils puissent
travailler cette idée d'études de marché
les résultats sont très positifs
encourageant et donc on décide de se
lancer et on propose à l'étudiant en
charge de l'étude de nous rejoindre nous
partons donc à trois pour faire cette
nouvelle aventure
un an et demi de préparation
un business plan glamour qui a permis
d'attirer de nombreux investisseurs
on a aussi beaucoup travaillé le montage
juridique on a pu lever des fonds
importants tout en gardant la majorité
et puis on a beaucoup travaillé entre
nous
la gouvernance de l'entreprise
tout va bien
un moment donné il faut se lancer
et donc on part d'une page blanche avec
une toute nouvelle offre
qui est vraiment extrêmement novatrice
sur le marché qui est demain deviendra
un nouveau métier on se répartit des
rôles entre mes associés et moi et je
suis en charge du développement du
business
mes clients sont plutôt les dirigeants
les directeurs financiers et de manière
incontournable les directeurs des
ressources humaines
es rien ne se passe comme prévu
entre
la belle étude de marché qu'on a eu et
le résultat il y a un monde d'écart
je n'ai pas signé un seul contrat
en six mois je ne vois pas la queue d'un
contrat
c'est la panique mettez-vous deux
secondes à ma place
les nuits sont très courtes
vous êtes dans le petit soulier
les nuits sont courtes et
le stress est vraiment très important
pas le bon stress le mauvais
c'est un peu de la panique à bord et les
associés avec qui les relations se
tendent un peu me convoquent pour une
réunion de crise
et je me souviens
de cette première réunion où il me dit
des fois mais qu'est-ce que tu fais on
en est où on va déposer le bilan avant
d'avoir fait le premier contrat
c'est la vanille totale tu vas nous
mettre dans un embarras absolu ça va
être la honte les actionnaires qui m'ont
fait confiance qu'est-ce qu'on va leur
dire
écoutez ces deux choses à vous dire la
première c'est que en tant que
responsable du développement commercial
je suis absolument incapable tétaniser
par l'idée de décrocher mon téléphone
pour appeler un dirigeant je ne connais
pas et lui raconter une histoire lui
proposer une offre qui ne connaît pas
non plus et quand je l'ai malheur d'en
avoir un au téléphone il me dit mais
avec qui vous travaillez qui je pourrais
contacter votre part pour avoir des
renseignements je n'ai personne
c'est très difficile c'est contre nature
pour moi de travailler ainsi en revanche
je ne suis pas resté à rien faire
pendant six mois
j'ai commencé à travailler le réseau
j'ai commencé à rencontrer des gens qui
me mettent avec d'autres je suis sûr que
ça va arriver je suis comme un paysan
qui sème sur une terre qui désire
fertile pour d'une part
radissait large c'est à dire prendre des
parts de marché et aussi demain être en
capacité de travailler nos clients en
profondeur l'amour est profond
mais me disent du coup de François tu es
bien gentil mais pour l'instant on ne
voit rien arriver et c'est pendant six
mois qui va falloir trouver des
contrastes il faut les signer maintenant
au pied du mur la première personne vers
qui je me tourne c'est mon papa
alors donc aviron mais voyez le réseau
le networking c'est du copinage c'est du
piston et ils auront tort sur toute la
ville c'est une école d'exigence qui
demande de travailler sans filet et de
faire un travail parfait sans quoi la
personne qui est à l'origine d'une mise
en nation
verra le problème arriver vers lui et
pas vers moi
il faut être impeccable quand on
travaille de la part de quelqu'un et
qu'on rencontre des décideurs
on parvenir ces phrases qui résonne
encore en moi du coup voilà je vais te
mettre en relation avec un DH
mon père était RH dans la vie
je vais te demander de faire du phrases
que tu voudras peut-être que tu signeras
pas tu te débrouilles mais
je veux que ce soit parfait je ne veux
jamais avoir l'ombre d'un doute
la moindre suspicion de sa part sur le
front sur la forme une la moindre
déception il faut que le travail soit
top
tout se sait et je saurai tout
la pression a été forte mais je n'avais
pas le choix donc je me suis dit allez
on y va
je rencontre ce DRH
quel jour après je signe mon premier
contrat
à partir de là
tout se passe bien on fait une belle
mission ou un rapport magnifique notre
client est super
mais on est encore très très loin du but
je n'ai qu'un seul client
et là je me dis mais est-ce que je ne
pourrais pas aller jusqu'au bout du
raisonnement que je produis depuis le
début sur la magie du réseau donc je
vais voir ce client là et je lui dis
écoutez vous êtes le seul client qu'on a
je vous demande de mettre et je vous
demande d'être au rendez-vous avec
l'histoire
voilà ce que j'aimerais c'est que si
vous étiez contente de travail vous
pourriez faire d'une pierre deux coups
m'aider mais aider aussi vos copains DRH
qui pourraient demain
rencontrer des gens comme nous pour
avoir la même création de valeur qu'on a
fait pour
vous et je lui dis moi ce que je vous
demande c'est de m'ouvrir votre cadet
d'adresse de la lettre A à la lettre Z
j'ai pas fait vraiment comme ça
afin que je puisse rencontrer de votre
part et dans les meilleures conditions
possibles et décideurs
je suis d'accord
je pense que mon discours avait un peu
ému il accepte
et donc je ne cherchais pas
à rencontrer un ambassadeur qui allait
être passif
qui me dirait mais monsieur la fait pas
de problème je vais vous pensez à trois
quatre personnes avec qui je vais vous
mettre en relation ou je vais envoyer
deux trois mails ici et puis peut-être
que demain j'aurai un DRH sur un
problème qui pourra vous annoncer je
ferai la connexion avec vous ça ne
marche jamais
je cherchais un ambassadeur
actif quelqu'un qui se mobilise à mes
côtés
par rapport à ça on a pris un
rendez-vous qui a duré deux bonnes
heures je me suis transformé en Sherlock
Holmes c'était en mode investigation
j'essayais de connecter ses réseaux avec
mes objectifs de travailler de manière
on va dire plus simplement l'aspect des
de l'économie qui était la scène et la
mienne
à l'issue de cette robe de ce
rendez-vous qui a duré deux heures je
suis reparti avec
50 en gros une cinquantaine de
dirigeants à contacter de sa part que du
top niveau
et là ça a tout changé parce que quand
j'ai contacté le premier je vais les
appartiens qui connaissait qu'il
appréciait le climat de confiance et de
confort c'est instaurer tout de suite
et j'ai signé mon deuxième contrat
puis un troisième
et puis est arrivé un quatrième contrat
particulier c'était de première
entreprise du CAC 40 et là on a signé
une mission pour les 50 filiales du
monde et là attention
je voyais mes associés de plus en plus
fébrile est-ce que vous connaissez
est-ce que vous avez l'intention de
l'arroseur arrosé
c'est assez jouissif pour moi à ce
moment-là
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé je suis allé
voir les associer j'aurais écouté mais
je sens que la production ne suit pas
on va déposer le bilan peut-être à cause
de vous
il y a peut-être falloir se bouger un
tout petit peu
et tu es vraiment très sympa ce petit
moment
ensuite on a mis ça en place de manière
récurrente on a peaufiné l'approche on a
amélioré
et je ne savais pas d'ailleurs qu'à ce
moment-là quelques années après j'en
aurai fait une méthode que j'ai eu le
plaisir et le bonheur de transmettre au
marché
je ne pourrais pas continuer mon
explication ça va vous parler de mon
premier recrutement
il a 53 ans
il est en recherche d'emploi
qui
recruterait aujourd'hui oui
une personne de 53 ans
sur la touche en recherche d'emploi
pour un poste de commercial
qui n'a jamais fait de commercial qui a
travaillé toute sa vie dans un grand
groupe un peu de directeur qui est un
salaire très élevé et qui en plus de ça
ne connaît strictement rien à mon métier
personne
visite dernièrement un article comme
quoi aujourd'hui en France à 45 ans on
est déjà Seigneur et à 50 ans ou 55 ans
c'est terminé c'est affreux on est dans
un pays complètement fou
pourquoi je vous parle de ça parce que
l'intérêt ça a été de décentrer la
manière de réfléchir think out of the
box
changée de paradigme regardez les choses
autrement
il y a un détail qui m'a beaucoup plu
chez ce monsieur là je rencontrais pour
la première fois c'est qu'il avait fait
un chaussée
ça veut rien dire du tout c'est pas un
passeport de ce qu'on a fait HEC mais je
trouvais intéressant de me dire mais
qu'est-ce qu'il a comme raison
je cherche finalement à regarder quelle
était la qualité de son oiseau et donc
je vais poser plein de questions par
rapport à ça
et je me suis rendu compte qu'il était
assis sur un trésor
ils ont disait rien parce qu'il n'avait
aucune idée de ce qu'il a
à ce moment-là je me suis dit mais
tous les gens qui connaissent se sont
que des dirigeants aujourd'hui
donc la masse était extraordinaire
on a décidé de recruter je peux vous
dire que vous avez mis quelques années
deux trois ans avant de retrouver la
rémunération qu'il avait c'est quand on
est une start-up c'est un événement qui
est important parce que le moindre
recrutement qui ne marche pas beaucoup
très cher vous payer cash
mais ça a été quelque chose
d'extraordinaire sa femme nous disait à
un moment donné qu'elle ne reconnaissait
plus qu'elle avait en face de lui plutôt
un gamin que quelqu'un de 53 ans
en fait mon travail à moi ça a été de
lui faire prendre conscience de la
qualité de son réseau
et de le faire accoucher
de ce qu'il avait entre les mains et
qu'il ne voyait pas
et donc il a lâché prise
et on a travaillé ensemble il a apporté
beaucoup d'entreprise et on a vraiment
grandi grâce à lui
la magie du réseau ça vous concerne tous
ici dans cette salle
je vous parle du développement
d'affaires par la puissance du réseau
mais je pourrais aussi vous dire la même
chose concernant la gestion des
communautés
je peux vous dire la même chose aussi
concernant le recrutement et aussi la
gestion de carrière
vous pouvez être un jour
en situation de recherche d'emploi
plutôt de manière
active ou passive
je m'explique
si demain vous êtes dans une entreprise
tout se passe bien vous avez fait le
tour du sujet et en fait vous auriez un
petit peu vous voulez partir ailleurs le
réseau sera un ami fidèle pour vous mais
si en plus de ça
vous êtes en position plutôt défensive
Coffe aussi
désolé c'est de se dire demain j'ai 48
ans j'ai mis trois enfants qui me
coûtent de plus en plus cher
un très bon salaire je suis licencié
seul seul le réseau
pourra vous aider
c'est très compliqué de trouver du
travail à plus de 50 ans et c'est le
réseau sur lequel arrivera les choses
je voudrais terminer rapidement par 5
points importants que vous pourriez
aujourd'hui prendre en considération
pour travailler votre réseau
beaucoup plus et mettre en place les
ingrédients qu'il faut après que ça soit
un succès
la première chose c'est de prendre
conscience du réseau que l'on a on ne
prend jamais le temps de le faire
mettez-vous devant une feuille blanche
et regardez votre réseau essayez de
l'animé de le faire vivre
surprenez le
et
en fait quelque chose
de ce qui est intéressant ce sont les
limites beaucoup des personnes que
j'accompagne aujourd'hui ont
d'énormément ont énormément de biais
cognitives ou si votre croyance
limitantes par rapport au réseau on
n'ose pas
seul ceux qui osent réussissent c'est
pas moi c'est de Georges il faut oser y
aller
oser s'exprimer et demander pour
beaucoup c'est quémander pour moi
demander c'est valoriser la personne qui
est en face ce qui n'a rien à voir donc
on a toujours des filtres dans la tête
il faut arriver à les enlever
donner en premier pour recevoir ensuite
c'est l'une des bases de la Turquie la
nature qui réussit
quand je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure de
l'aspect du développement d'affaires
pour bien vous comprenez les choses
c'est que on a dans cette approche là un
taux d'effort qui est très réduit pour
des résultats élevés
on a beaucoup de plaisir et de sens de
confort et de reconnaissance derrière
avec des conséquences tout à fait
incroyables en matière de management et
leadership parce que le plaisir est au
rendez-vous les résultats arrivent ce
que je vous ai pas dit aussi c'est
important c'est que sept ans après la
création
on avait plus de 2000 clients
que des entreprises du CAC 40 et 900
que des groupes qui ont été acquis à 99%
par cette action de boucherie très
structurée très structurant
au lieu de très bons résultats
financiers et on s'est introduit en
bourse
vous comprendrez bien que c'est pas la
bourse qui m'intéresse on s'en fiche
c'est pas non plus resta financier ce
qui est intéressant c'est le chemin
d'entreprise c'est pas le résultat c'est
le comment et le pourquoi bien sûr on a
beaucoup travaillé on a eu des moments
extraordinaires avec les salariés qui se
sont comportés en vrai entrepreneur dans
l'entreprise on y met en place une
gouvernance solide en améliore qui était
extraordinaire mais ce qui a vraiment
marché ça a été la puissance
extraordinaire du réseau sans limite
intégrer une méthode le fond la forme
intégrer une méthode ça veut dire aussi
s'impliquer par rapport à ça qu'est-ce
qui marque qu'est-ce qui marche pas
c'est vraiment un élément très important
sans méthode n'était pas
il y a le front et la forme il y a aussi
St postural et comportemental avec
l'aspect aussi derrière du process
qu'est-ce que je fais à quel moment
pourquoi
développer le lien de réciprocité
le don contre don ce que je fais
aujourd'hui pour toi tu feras demain
pour moi
ça donne beaucoup de sens
moi j'ai un client un jour qui me reçoit
très rapidement et qui me dit écoutez
j'aurais pas dû recevoir jamais dans le
problème j'ai un décès dans mon
entreprise mais elles sont du travail
convaincu au tribunal je ne sais pas
quoi faire c'est la première fois que ça
m'arrive vous écoutez moi je peux rien
faire pour vous la seule chose que je
peux faire
c'est de vous mettre en relation avec le
meilleur avocat que je connaisse là
dessus le ténor du barreau sur votre
problème
est-ce qu'il a fait c'est ce qu'on a
fait et je n'ai pas une nouvelle de ce
que tu penses six mois et un jour il me
rappelle d'écouter il faut que je vous
dise j'ai été relaxé grâce à la mise en
relation que vous m'avez fait
on va prendre un déjeuner ensemble et
quelques idées à vous soumettre
et on merveilleux d'avoir pu agir
simplement et d'avoir aussi du résultat
c'est un élément fondateur fondamental
d'un travail réseau réussi
soyez enfin créateur d'opportunités
posez-vous la question est-ce que ce que
je fais le rapproche de ça parce que je
m'en éloigné
mettez la sironidité le hasard au cœur
de votre c'est un peu conceptuel mais ça
ouvre des champs incroyables et je
terminerai simplement sur cette citation
de Paul Eluard qui ont beaucoup il n'y a
pas de hasard il n'y a que des
rencontres je vous laisse méditer par
rapport à cette phrase là qui vous ouvre
les portes pour développer avec passion
votre propre réseau
[Applaudissements]